[Applauso]
[Musica]
Ciao a tutti Come state è un onore
essere qui e
Balance quando mi è stato chiesto di
fare questo tet Talk mi stavo vivendo un
momento di estrema Balance non so per
quale motivo ma ho accettato di essere
qui oggi forse
consapevole dell'ipocrisia che avrei
potuto inscenare su questo palco o
fiduciosa nel mio subconscio nel momento
in cui ha accettato questa sfida
Balance
mantenersi in equilibrio
è un obiettivo apparentemente così
lontano dalla mia natura ma che in
realtà io e tutti noi siamo capaci di
comprendere di capire di sentire
ancora più oggi ancora di più oggi che
siamo in un momento in cui la società è
bulimica veloce richiede da noi una
quantità di energie che non sono
naturali per il nostro flusso di vita ci
inculca
atteggiamenti tossici Ci
manda solo a
raggiungere stimoli che non sono
positivi per il nostro
Balance per il nostro wellbin e noi
siamo lì che stiamo cercando di far
funzionare tutto come degli equilibristi
e di cercare di tenere le redini di
tutto con estrema fatica
tutti noi abbiamo un'idea di equilibrio
e anche se non vi viene subito in mente
Vi chiedo quindi di
fidarvi e chiudere gli occhi un secondo
possiamo disegnarlo questo equilibrio
però voglio fare prima un esercizio con
voi
chiudete gli occhi e non apriteli
siete in una stanza
c'è il letto c'è la finestra il comodino
la porta i cuscini e sul letto è seduto
un bambino una bambina quel bambino e
quella bambina siete voi
provate empatia vero immagino
quando pensiamo ai bambini il primo
istinto è quello di proteggerli di voler
far sì che loro siano sereni felici sani
figuriamoci se poi ci rendiamo conto che
quel bambino di cui stiamo parlando
siamo noi il quale vi si sta aprendo
vero
avete il potere quindi di parlargli ora
prendetevi questo momento
è iniziata a comunicare con lui o con
lei fategli domande capite come sta
giocate con lui o lei
chiedete le sue prospettive di vita cosa
lo renderebbe lo renderebbe felice
attendete
ascoltate accogliete la risposta e
sentite
vedete Vi ho chiesto di fare questo
esercizio perché
volevo aiutarvi a visualizzare
a visualizzarvi in un contesto di
purezza in un contesto energetico di
amore di comprensione
la prima volta che ho realmente compreso
l'importanza dell'essere responsabili
per se stessi per le proprie energie è
stato quando ha visualizzato me da
bambina mi sono presa in braccio mi sono
amata
e mi sono promessa che mi sarei presa
cura di entrambe
Quindi cosa ci è successo poco fa è
molto semplice avete inscenato un
dialogo interiore
avete avuto questo dialogo con la
bambina e il bambino che portate dentro
e chi vivrà con voi per il resto della
vostra vita
le risposte alla fine sono dentro di noi
sempre abbiamo una verità universale che
ci fa muovere nel mondo che ci fa
connettere tra di noi
però
non credo esistono risposte universali
comunque
nel
in una situazione più pratica adesso in
velocità in un momento in cui la nostra
società è totalmente celebrale e poco
emotiva e sensibile
vi dirò il mio punto di vista dato che
penso di essere qui per questo
tenete sempre in mente l'immagine del
bambino ci servirà per andare avanti con
questo discorso
vi avviso già da adesso che energia sarà
una delle parole che utilizzerò di più
in questo
Ted Talk uno perché come ben vedete
faccio parte della generazione Z è New
York
e quindi partiamo con il parlare di
energie scambio energetico capire cosa
sono un mio amico una volta mi ha detto
una cosa illuminante bisogna imparare ad
essere sostenibili per la propria vita e
non penso si riferisse solamente alla
questione di sostenibilità
ecologica di sostenibilità dell'ambiente
ma una sostenibilità energetica è come
se quando nascessimo ci venissero date
un certo numero di energie un certo
numero di fish di
vite per un videogioco e come se
dovessimo finire
[Musica]
responsabili ed essere responsabili per
Dove andranno a finire queste energie
già da subito
c'è stato un momento in cui ero davvero
davvero scarica
apparentemente stavo investendo tutto
quello che avevo nel lavoro ottenevo
risultati Quindi pensavo che il mio
stile di vita fosse Ottimo ma
evidentemente
mi sbagliavo perché in realtà stavo così
avevo raggiunto obiettivi di cui essere
fiera stavo facendo il lavoro che amavo
stavo guadagnando soldi
La gente mi fermava per strada Eppure
stavo così
ho la fortuna di fare un lavoro
Bellissimo amo il mio lavoro Amo fare
musica ma non riesco a mettere uno
speciale uno switch off non c'è un
momento in cui spengo è un lavoro
esigente è un mercato che richiede
tantissimo Dalle dagli esseri umani è un
mercato bulimico e un mercato veloce in
questo contesto ti criticano e poi ti
amano un momento sei sul palco davanti a
migliaia di persone con un microfono e
senti il potere del mondo tra le tue
mani e un secondo dopo sei solo in un
camerino
per un periodo ho messo tutta me stessa
sul piatto Anzi sul palco e ho messo
ogni mia goccia di energia nel mio
lavoro
ma se lo fai a lungo non hai più per
tutto il resto è tutto il resto è vita è
fondamentale
sono arrivata al mio primo Burnout
Ho 25 anni a 24 fatto
questa esperienza assurda di sentirmi
completamente persa di avere paura un
estrema paura
non vi nego che
[Musica]
sono una persona estremamente emotiva ho
un carico emotivo molto forte mi ci
infilo nelle emozioni mi piace proprio
andare verticalmente sentire tutto ma
credo anche che questa mia
modalità di essere
sia un po' In opposizione con il
concetto di equilibrio
arrivo così il mio primo Burnout vi
dicevo
Cosa succede il mio subconscio quindi in
questo momento mi impone Un'unica cosa
andarmene by se il tuo imparo in mente
non ti sta aiutando
Vai
decido di andare in Amazzonia
passo qualche settimana con una
popolazione indigena vicino all'acre gli
ascenica
il contesto più lontano da quello che mi
aveva portato a soffrire a sentirmi of
Balance in quel momento mi stava
accogliendo a braccia aperte come se
fossi figlia loro
pregavamo ogni notte partecipavo alle
loro cerimonie piantavamo semi per poi
far rifiorire e riforestare l'amazzonia
e in quel momento stavo anche facendo
riforestare me stessa senza neanche
accorgermene
ricordo che era appena nato un bambino
Quando nella comunità degli Asciano
incan nasce un figlio non è solo dei
genitori È della comunità Quindi quando
madre è stanca o il padre sta lavorando
o viceversa
la comunità si prende cura dell'infanzia
in quel momento ho capito il senso reale
di Slow Life che non è una Slow Life che
intendiamo noi come
mettersi a bere del vino buono mangiare
vedere la bellezza del posto che ci
circonda in cui abbiamo la fortuna di
essere nati ma life in connessione con
la natura con ritmi naturali come alla
fine lo siamo noi naturali
in quell'istante È come se mi fosse
sentita parte di un tutto più grande mi
sono sentita un po' come Jake quando in
Avatar diventa un navi
il mio esempio forse estremo non c'è
bisogno di andare in Amazzonia per
ritrovare se stessi però è stato Life
Change e quindi vorrei un attimo
analizzare il perché e il per come il
mio andare lì non era la volontà di
eliminare tutto quello che avevo
costruito prima o di stracciare
l'identità che avevo costruito per me
stessa e il mio lavoro e mi affetti e
tutto quello che mi rendeva a me però
era l'intento di tornare a civare la mia
anima a creare un rapporto immediato con
essa per limitare gli squilibri
interiori che la mia vita e la società
fino ad allora avevano normalizzato
fuggire dall'individualismo dalla paura
di fallire dalla paura di se stessi
riconnettermi con la natura per capire
che io sono lei che lei sono io e che
noi siamo tutto in un equilibrio
perfetto
quindi in quel momento ho deciso di
riprendere la forza di tornare a
prendermi cura di me stessa da bambina e
anche della mia adulta
dopo che sono tornata dall'amazzonia Ho
iniziato a capire qualcosina di più
tutti i tasselli e le tessere
cominciavano a trovare i loro posto ad
incastrarsi ho elaborato una mia teoria
Anzi la chiamerei più una strategia che
sicuramente sta funzionando per me può
essere risolutiva non per tutti ma
vorrei condividerle in questo momento
con voi
la mia ricerca dell'equilibrio ha tre
pilastri essenziali il primo Pilastro
No
è la spiritualità e la tecnologia non è
mai stata mia amica Comunque la
spiritualità
Per me sentire è fondamentale siamo
stati ci hanno insegnato che la mente è
quello che guida il nostro percorso di
vita in realtà il nostro sentire la
mentre la mente arriva solamente in
funzione del nostro cuore
torniamo al bambino nella stanza Cosa
succede quando provi empatia nei
confronti di qualcuno quando vuoi il suo
bene la tua vibrazione immediatamente si
leva diventi amore e mani una frequenza
in armonia qui non si parla quindi di
una Fede che sia per forza religiosa non
si parla neanche di una propria
filosofia astratta si parla di un
sentire che vada oltre la materialità la
spiritualità è una componente che ti
permette quindi di raggiungere la
vibrazione energetica di quello che vuoi
ottenere e di quello che vuoi essere
Dobbiamo capire Quindi come togliere
l'auto Pilot dalle nostre vite Dobbiamo
essere noi a guidare questa macchina
perché la spiritualità in questo è
fondamentale è la componente che fa sì
che Ci permettiamo di vivere una vita in
presenza
A proposito di questo oggi si parlava
tanto di equilibrio tra vita privata e
lavoro e credo che sia diventato un Big
Show
tante persone purtroppo nel loro lavoro
non riescono a trovare un senso un
parpes una coerenza con quello che sono
e con quello che vorrebbero essere
quello che vorrebbero mettere nel mondo
quindi questo li porta a pensare al
lavoro come a un dovere
se pensiamo quindi ad una bilancia a due
piatti e su un piatto mettiamo il lavoro
e sull'altro la vita privata noteremo
che queste persone arriveranno a
caricare tutta la loro professione e
tutte le questioni lavorative su un
unico piatto chiaramente non sarà più in
Balance quella situazione
e non abbiamo appunto neanche abbastanza
vita per controbilanciare questo aspetto
quando tra il tuo lavoro e quello che
sei la distanza è un po' più piccola è
minima e fai quello che ti piace non
lavorerai la distribuzione dei carichi
Perdonatemi sarà molto più equilibrata
molto più smussa la vita sarà più fluida
e in armonia questo non vuol dire che se
fai quello che ami significa non
lavorare Un giorno nella tua vita Devi
lavorare è lavoro c'è bisogno di sforzo
c'è bisogno di energie spese Però se fai
quello che ti ami L'equilibrio è
sicuramente molto più semplice da
raggiungere
il mio secondo Pilastro è l'auto
conoscimento
quando pensiamo al bambino di prima la
bambina di prima pensiamo a nessun
piccolo essere umano in realtà che ha
già questa personalità arriva in questo
mondo con la sua attitu della sua
visione ma che in realtà deve ancora
crescere devo ancora formare No la sua
identità i suoi punti di vista e per
farlo fa tante domande perché perché
perché perché perché
Ecco noi dobbiamo fare la stessa cosa
quotidianamente risvegliando quel
bambino e Quella curiosità per
conoscerci dentro per capire come
guidare la nostra macchina la mia per
esempio è questa navicella spaziale e
terrestre con tette e tanta Attitude
senza autocoscimento quindi non si va da
nessuna parte è come mettere le mani in
un motore e non sapere da dove iniziare
rimani bloccato
a volte doloroso perché non sempre ci
piace conoscere davvero tutto di noi
stessi la sincerità è complicata È
dolorosa
e anche la sincerità un muscolo che va
allenato e il miglior modo per farlo è
chiedersi perché ho fatto questo perché
l'ho fatto per davvero
per me è stato decisivo leggere un libro
The power of Now di Edgar all
mi ha insegnato per la prima volta un
profondo senso di consapevolezza di me
dell'esterno del mio potenziale e del
potenziale di tutti
mi ha portato a creare un atteggiamento
positivo nel capire perché faccio quello
che faccio e perché penso quello che
penso se rimaniamo presenti nel momento
stesso in cui viviamo Allora siamo vivi
in questo modo è possiamo controllare la
nostra mente abbiamo la abilità di
essere divini
Io ho sempre avuto un rapporto
complicato con la mente come molti di
voi Penso essere schiavi del proprio
circolo di pensieri e alla base del
nostro squilibrio interiore
ci siamo dissociati da noi stessi mente
corpo e anima non collaborano ci
ammaliamo ci arrabbiamo se ci sentiamo
persi ma se ti rendi conto che
incastrandoci proprio in questi pensieri
che sono un fabbricato della nostra
testa delle paure delle insicurezze che
abbiamo riesci in quel momento ad andare
oltre e vivere in equilibrio
e equilibrio anche smettere di cercare
fuori quello che in realtà dobbiamo
trovare dentro
a volte per trovare equilibrio cerchiamo
giustamente di fortuna Ci appelliamo ai
soldi alle relazioni al lavoro cerchiamo
stabilità in quello però appena
cerchiamo fuori
tutto crolla dentro è molto veloce è
molto veloce quel tipo di sicurezza non
ci si può fidare molto
il vero equilibrio Quindi è una ricerca
di
profonda interiorizzazione di quello che
siamo
il terzo punto è
l'azione e il movimento
sensazione E senza movimento il tuo
salto di equilibrio sarà solo un grande
sogno non posso essere Briga pigra non
possa rendermi all'inerzia devo essere
consapevole che per far sì che quella
magia della spiritualità e
l'autoconscimento che mi dà gli
strumenti poi per capire dove
direzionare la mia vita c'è bisogno
anche di un passo e un altro e un altro
ancora
la Stasi porta solo ad insoddisfazione
insoddisfazione porta distaccamento
dalla realtà e depressione outfissions e
oltre e altre cose che ho già vissuto in
prima persona e me e che spero di non
vivere ancora
cosa intendo nel pratico operazione Io
per esempio la mattina la prima cosa che
devo fare è prendermi 20/30 minuti per
camminare
torniamo un passo prima respirare
mi prendo questi 20 30 minuti a volte
un'ora e mezza inizio cammino mi metto
nelle orecchie un audiolibro delle
frequenze
dei podcast di mindfulness inizia a
meditare mi porto il mio taccuino e
scrivo scrivo cose che mi possano
aiutare progetto La mia giornata e
quindi mi tolgo da quel sistema costante
di ansia
e vivo la bellezza di essere vivi con
gratitudine
gratitudine perché in quel momento sto
attivando
l'endorfine nel camminare quindi sto già
aiutando il mio benessere mentale fisico
e in più sto alzando la mia vibrazione
energetica aiutando anche me stessa
visualizzare quello che vorrò fare con
molta più efficacia
prima di andare fuori nel mondo so che
devo dare da bere a me stessa Prima devo
dissetarmi io perché altrimenti non avrò
energie da dare agli altri
l'azione quindi è essenziale se il tuo
subconscio non è pronto per attivarsi tu
puoi fare tutto il positive tanking e la
visualizzazione che vuoi ma ricadrai
sempre nei soliti percorsi strutturali
che la tua menta ha costruito
hai bisogno quindi di abituare te stesso
ad essere quello che vuoi essere è un
allenamento
arrivati Quindi a questo punto credo che
sia chiaro che non esiste una persona
sempre equilibrata
che sia una continua ricerca e un
continuo allenamento il muscolo del
Balance quindi va allenato e da ognuno
di noi va fatto in maniera estremamente
personale
di questa parola l'equilibrio potrei
stare a parlare per ore perché mi
affascina perché mi tormenta
e sto imparando anche io a creare il mio
equilibrio A poco a poco proprio come un
genitore fa con suo figlio mi sono
responsabilizzata e ho imparato ad avere
cura della bambina Nella stanzetta
attivando il suo spirito
rispondendo alle sue domande invitandola
a fare quello che è necessario per far
funzionare il meglio la sua navicella
terrestre
io l'ho detto non volevo dare soluzioni
ma offrire la mia prospettiva essere una
persona sempre equilibrata E decisamente
impossibile ma avere la consapevolezza
che tutto questo sarà per sempre un work
in progress è già di per sé uno stadio
fondamentale della ricerca
dell'equilibrio interiore
vi lascio con una citazione di Tolle
niente di ciò che vedi là fuori Ti
soddisferà mai se non temporaneamente
superficialmente ma potreste aver
bisogno di sperimentare molte
disillusioni prima di realizzare quella
verità Quindi vi chiedo di vivere
conoscere conoscervi guidare la vostra
navicella e l'equilibrio che desiderate
sarà sempre di più un vostro alleato
Buon allenamento e grazie per l'ascolto